your number-one job is to become more of
yourself and to grow yourself into the
best of yourself you wake up in the
morning and you're dreading going to
work dude do something else do something
else everybody talked about going to the
next level everybody talked about next
level living everybody wearing a t-shirt
everybody's talking it and - it's time
to pay up and when it's time to pay
their people not willing to pay
goodmorning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I believe in your potential and I
want to see that come out to help you go
off and find that amazing thing inside
you unleash it out into the world I
started to believe life seriously try to
tackle some more personal issues
personal development topics that
hopefully if you can apply it to your
life you will be unstoppable so today
we're gonna look at how to become your
best self and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in comments below and put quotes
around us or other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
[Music]
follow your passion first first first
first first first when I retired from
the game I said they're asking kind of
all the wrong questions it was the
biggest industry I can get into and it's
all the wrong stuff and you got to sit
there and ask yourself okay what am I
truly passionate about what do I enjoy
doing and when you feel that way
honestly I mean you feel like you have
never worked in your life it's the most
fun thing in the world you get up in the
morning excited about what you're doing
and you got to be really honest with
yourself about it if you wake up in the
morning and you're dreading going to
work dude do something else do something
else and those are hard decisions to
make but when you make those decisions
it's a very liberating experience and
you find out that the rewards will come
I get up at crazy hours whether it's 3
o'clock in the morning by the way when
we're talking in London I was getting up
at 3:00 because I had to be on set by
4:00 I'm sorry by 7:00 so whatever time
my call time is and I tell this to
Studios and directors and our producers
whatever tell my call time so my call
time is at 7:00 then you back your clock
up for hours and then that's when I get
up and train twice I'll get my cardio in
and breakfast and I'll go hit the
weights clanging and banging we call it
jack and iron but like what time do you
go to bed I mean you might shoot really
late at night I'm averaging on a movie
on average probably about five hours of
sleep your girl's gonna be like your
wings spending time together like your
girl gonna test you your man gonna test
you like you like I want to be a lawyer
I want to be a doctor I want to you know
I want to be an engineer you study and I
gotta focus your mom's gonna be a hurt
your family gonna thank you you know you
better than everybody else your people
don't challenge you like where are you
like you too good for us but I'm trying
to tell you number three you got to make
a sacrifice if you're gonna get you the
next level you're gonna have to give up
something right you're gonna have to
give up something and I'm just gonna
keep it real with y'all when I say give
up when I talk about sacrifice I'm
saying give up your current blessings
like it's gonna be hard give up the
current blessings or you hear what I'm
telling you I had to make a sacrifice
and so what I mean by sacrifice again is
giving a
that which is in your hand giving that
thing up that's like right in your head
that the thing that you can see that you
can touch that you can take like the
thing that you holding onto risking
everything I have now for what could be
are you here to me that's tough and for
an entire year I wasn't answering the
phone like that y'all I was I wasn't I
wasn't doing the entertainment thing I
wasn't going out like that on the
weekends with my girl like that I wasn't
spending as much time as I would like to
with my family and my hearing what I'm
telling you
number three is gonna be the most
important one you know write it down
shut it down yeah but that might last
for about two weeks before it started
getting to you like it might last a
month 30 days before it starts getting
to you when people start walking out
your life and people start calling you
out right and you start losing stuff to
gang stuff listen to me
I'm talking to somebody you're ready to
give up you're ready to give up on break
as good as telling you buy and I'm
telling you to look good in the face
look good in the face and say bye bye
look look as the opportunities you have
now and say bye-bye to those so you can
get greater opportunities are you a hear
me it's gonna take a sacrifice and
everybody talks that off everybody talk
about going to the next level everybody
talk about next level living everybody
wearing a t-shirt everybody talking it
and - it's time to pay up and when it's
time to pay their people who not willing
to pay you gonna have to sacrifice some
sleep to get this one yep you can't get
up at the same time you're gonna have to
sacrifice some friendships to get to
this one you gonna have to sacrifice
some entertainment to get to this one
and the only way you point to yourself
that you really wanted when you really
want it is that you no longer hit the
snooze button you no longer you no
longer lose focus when you're studying
you no longer take shortcuts you no
longer playing games you are willing to
do whatever it takes whatever it takes
I'll do whatever it takes to get to that
milestone and if you don't have that in
you
dear baby I'm telling you on average you
will not integrate without making a
great sacrifice it's your boy et sense
if it was easy to do yeah if it was easy
to hit milestones everybody would be
hitting them every single day it ain't
easy but it's doable but only to those
who are willing to give up to go up and
you got to ask yourself this question
are you really really really really
ready to make the sacrifices necessary
to get to the next level and that answer
is yes but I guarantee you I guarantee
you it's only a matter of time before
that dream is no longer dream which you
are living
so do me a favor make the sacrifice so
that you can make the rest of your life
the best of your life we know how to
organize our world yeah we don't do it
we know how to organize our health and
yet very few people do it we know all
these things the right path to like
being like a happy healthy person is to
do all that we already know you're
supposed to do take care of your body
take care of your health take care of
your mind your stress meditate be kind
to people we all know that you mean to
ask anybody they know how to get by and
to be the the the the most evolved
version of you that you can be I mean
it's not like a magical checklist if you
talk to people about it you said okay
here you got a person you want to
improve them what are the things you're
gonna do to them okay well if I was a
life coach the first thing I would say
is this guy's got to get on a diet that
makes him healthy
I don't mean a diet just to lose weight
I mean just healthy foods in your body
mmm many many vegetables vegetables a
lot of good good quality protein a lot
of water stop the sodas stop the Bulls
start working out your body and get a
better sense of like how this machine
feels when it's moving it's flowing
better there's less tension in it your
mind feels like relaxed and you enjoy
every single moment of the day better
step one everybody knows that step right
what's step two be cool to people be
nice to as many people as you can smile
him as many people as you can have them
smile back at you tip well when you go
to restaurants just do the most you can
be as nice as you can you know and just
still manage to not have people walk all
over you
just get through this life it's nice in
Japan what else do what you want to do
with your life right don't don't go be
doing something you don't enjoy don't do
something that's don't get locked into
you know a car that you can't afford and
doing something crazy because you need
the money don't don't do that do what
you want to do do what the is it that
you really want to do because if someone
else is doing it you can do it you know
I mean everybody makes their own path
through this world but a lot of people
don't follow the path that they really
feel pulled to you know there's for
whatever reason they've got negative
programming you know when they were kids
someone told them that couldn't do it or
told them to take the shortcut or or
take the the shore route
that's a sad thing man when you talk to
dudes especially like talented dudes and
they don't follow up with what they want
to do you know your wounds and your
failures will teach you some of the most
important lessons that you will ever
learn in life if you are willing to
listen to them instead of complaining
about them what often happens when we
have a fairly when we have a setback
when things don't go our way instead of
trying to learn from them and say how
can I do better what can I learn from
this so that the next time it doesn't
happen again
we often shut down we often say well
that didn't work out and so this sucks
and it's this person's fault and I'm
never gonna be a success you start
blaming other people and start
complaining instead of taking
responsibility insane what can I learn
from this how can I make this better and
quite often from the lowest lows that
you'll have ever in your life come the
highest highs because you've changed
because you've grown because you've
broken the mold because you've you're
that Phoenix rising now and you see that
over and over and over again in success
stories their greatest Heights came as a
result of some deep dark place and so
don't stay down in that hole use that as
leverage to learn and grow into
something new
grow into that better version of
yourself stop procrastinating focus on
your goals when you focus on what you
want what you don't want or
automatically leave your life don't
focus on eliminating anything focus on
creating what you want so you're either
gonna spend all your energies
eliminating what you don't want or you
spend your energies creating what you
want
we all have alibis we're all busy busy
doing what I'm gonna challenge you stay
focus on your goals and if you don't
have goals write your goals
one of the greatest enemies of
fulfillment of purpose is
procrastination and broken focus if you
start now and you say 365 days from
today's date this is what I want to
accomplish and you do one a day
pull set focus this one thing I do I'm
focusing you do one a day at the end of
one year you will have made 365 steps
towards fulfillment of purpose who is
not going to be successful at the end of
their life who's not going to be
prosperous at the end of their life if
they could fulfill that so I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you where you
are in the language with the people with
the circumstances and experiences that
you can understand and interpret if you
are willing to see that always life God
is speaking to you now it took me a
while to actually really get this and to
understand it but once I did I started
paying attention to everything and one
of the reasons why I can now accept the
fact that I can offer my gatherings of
information and wisdom and call myself a
spiritual teacher is that every single
person who ever came on my show and I
hear there's like 37,000 guests I've
talked to a lot of them came from
dysfunction and a lot of them wouldn't
appear to be teachers but every one of
them had something to say that was
meaningful and valuable and that I could
use to grow myself into the best of
myself which is what all of our jobs are
your number one job is to become more of
yourself and to grow yourself into the
best of yourself
I really think mindset is everything
and so you've got a really designing and
a positive about things and negative
done things am i thrilled that i have
the ability to do things about it to
make what I'm worried about better or my
crippled by there's like these seven
things like tomorrow I always choose
positivity I look at other people around
me it's not just about me that winning
they choose positivity I look at people
around me that are not winning that are
not progressing they're not advancing
their issues and negativity it's
stunningly binary it's stunningly black
and white it's stunningly err me
this is uh this is really up to you but
really to be very honest to be very
frank I think the biggest impact of
having is I beat up all the emails
because I read a lot of them last night
as well is is shifting that mindset and
getting people into that and making them
understand what they're in charge of
that and and hacking and trying to pour
out the negativity dump the negativity
Madame positively dump the negativity
and positive definite if 'ti that
identity I'm a positivity to your world
that's what I'm pushing that's my agenda
and and that's why I think it really
affects and I need to find more of that
in your partner and loved one there is
inspiring audience so many people get 49
comments for me phenomenal
ones like your piece and they spend 80
percent on that one
[Music]
your habits determine what direction
you're going your success in life your
results in life are in direct proportion
to your habits what deep not what you
say you're gonna do but what are you
gonna do you've got to develop
successful habits and I believe that
starts with being a daily goal setter in
a daily goal hitter that you get them
you know too many people spend their
whole life they say they're dreaming but
they're really just pipe dreams they're
thinking about what they want to be
doing in 20 years and what their plans
are way out in the future let me tell
you what the future you need to be
worried about is not the next 20 years
but the next 20 minutes what are you
gonna be doing what are you gonna be
doing to be effective when you get up
every day know your priorities life will
overwhelm you stuff will overwhelm you
the with all the information we have now
whether it's your phone where sometimes
I think we have smart phones and stupid
people I mean it is so easy to get
consumed by a bunch of stuff that is not
gonna get you where you want to get to
say every day I will do today what
others don't so I will have tomorrow
what others won't you've got to choose
to be effective know what your
priorities are know what your must dues
are don't let your phone don't let your
you know your tablet don't let the TV
don't let your friends knock you off
what are the most important things to
get done today Sir Winston Churchill
didn't have an inbox he had an action
this day box and so things didn't get
into that box
that he wasn't gonna deal with that day
so may as John Wooden said make today
your masterpiece get up today
and get it done finish the day attack
the day and go change your life
second insight if you want to be more
inspired nature one of my favorite pop
protocols is the daily nature walk I
love walking in the woods I often listen
to audio books in the woods
I call it walk reading while walking
reading while walking so I go to this
place it's sort of my creative forest
there's not a lot of people in there and
I walk for one hour I breathe in the air
I look at the lush scenery I listen to a
different audiobook I it's almost like a
walking meditation as well sometimes I
don't listen to an audio book and I just
walk and I touch the earth it's almost
like I'm thanking the earth connecting
with the soil yes I'm wearing shoes I
don't want to get too esoteric here but
there's a lot of really good research
saying if you want to boost your immune
system you want to boost your happiness
you want to release serotonin and
dopamine you want to release the fear
hormone called cortisol walk in nature
and so when I walk I connect with nature
and like I say I know I'm not being very
elegant in this mastery session I'm just
being real but I listen to the audio
books and then other times I do a
walking meditation where I feel my feet
on the soil you know what I do other
times if there's something I'm confused
about I sort of just talk it out it's
like I'm talking out loud trying to work
it out if I'm in pain I get the negative
negative energy out of my system by just
releasing it by talking about it I also
and I know this sounds a little
unorthodox but I I do like a a walking
blessing meditation so while I'm walking
I started to challenge myself to come up
with 50 things I'm grateful for and
again I verbalize those because it's
only me and the squirrels in the it's
hoping me and the squirrels in the woods
and so I say I'm grateful for my family
I'm grateful for my health
I'm grateful for work that feeds my soul
I am grateful for the sunset I watched
I'm grateful for my team I'm grateful
for my business I'm grateful for the
travels that I get to take I'm grateful
for the people that I've served and
literally while I'm walking I say out
loud I am grateful for I hope it doesn't
sound strange for you because it's an
incredible protocol to install so thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
think of this video what are you going
to take from this and immediately apply
it somehow into your life or your
business I would love to hear your
thoughts please leave it down in the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to cam Jennings cam
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and for the
support on your YouTube channel to help
give us some exposure I really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
you enjoyed the book on the call we have
one Evan Carmichael owner and operator
of Evan Carmichael comm so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love guys I'll see you soon if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
people leave nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]